[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Then why don't we get started
here. So happy Thursday,
everybody. Welcome to
the Data Science Hangout,
and hope everybody's
having a great week.
If we have never met
before, I'm Rachael Dempsey.
I lead our Pro Community
and lead Customer Marketing at Posit.
The Data Science Hangout is our
open space to chat about data
science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear what's
going on in the world of data
across different industries.
And so I like to add,
if you are watching
this sometime in the future,
maybe on YouTube,
and we will start to get some
of those past weeks up there pretty soon,
and you want to join us live,
you can just use the link
below in the YouTube description to
add it to your calendar
and join us in the conversation.
But at the Data
Science Hangout,
we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everybody. We love
to hear from everyone,
no matter your years of
experience, titles, industry,
or even languages
that you work in.
So it's totally OK to just
listen in if you want.
Maybe you're doing
some work on the side,
and we're just in
the background, that's OK.
But there's also three ways you
can jump in and ask questions
or provide your
own perspective. So
for anybody who hasn't been
here before, those three ways
are, you can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And always feel free to put
a little star next to that
question if it's something you
want me to read instead maybe
you're in a coffee
shop or something.
And then we also have a
Slido link where you can ask
questions anonymously.
And so
we're doing things a
little bit different today,
and we're ready for it. We've
done this a few times here.
But we actually don't have
one featured leader today.
We are all the featured
leaders today. So
this will be an open
conversation with all of us.
And we can all ask
each other questions
to the broader audience
and jump in and share
our experience too.
But I'll get us going and
kick us off on a topic.
But if there's something that's
top of mind for you definitely
share it into the
chat here too.
And at least I love it.
Yes, I'm finally a featured leader.
But something I've been
thinking a lot about lately is,
of course, presentations because the
Posit conference is next week.
And I know there's been
a lot of preparation happening in
terms of talks and slides.
So I thought that could be
a fun starting point for us
to hear what lessons have you
all maybe learned along the way
in giving conference talks or
even presentations at your own company?
And I'm just curious
if anybody has
some tips or things
to share with us.
I see
some things in the chat about GIFs.
- I was trying to drop
in a funny GIF. It doesn't work.
- Could you repeat
the question.
I came in halfway
through it being asked.
- Yeah.
So I was just starting
off the conversation with everybody about
presentations because Posit conference
is top of mind for
me with it happening next week.
And to just understand
if anybody had any
tips or lessons
learned in giving
conference talks or the
way that you do your slide
preparation as well.
OK. Abigail,
I might call on you
first because I just read yours
first. Is that OK?
ABIGAIL: Yes, I'm
in a coffee shop,
so tell me if you
can't understand me.
- I can hear you.
ABIGAIL: OK. Yeah. So, look,
just this whole approach of
like, look, I'm a
nerd. I like coding.
I want to show people code,
but that's just never the answer.
You think it's going
to be the answer,
but really it's like reverse
engineering what it's going to
be answer to my audience and
not treating this as this is an
opportunity for me to talk but
treating this as what is it
that's actually going to
be useful in somebody's life.
- Absolutely.
That's great. Mike,
I see you had your
hand raised too.
I didn't notice that before.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Yeah. Thanks.
Yeah, Abigail's advice
is absolutely spot on,
but we've had
Articulation training.
Articulation is a
consultancy group.
We've been working with
Posit to help the speakers
get ready for Posit Conf,
and the advice
has been absolutely fantastic.
I've fundamentally changed what
my slide deck and presentation
looks like from
before I started.
What they got us
to think about is,
what is the hook? So what
is the thing that you're going
to try and draw people's
attention in because we're all
dreadfully distracted
by everything
in the room?
And so you want to hook people
in, and then what are, if you
like, three key
items that you're going to
want them to remember later.
And then once you've
got those things,
you may or may not have a
call to action at the end
of the presentation. But
once what is your hook,
so what is the key theme,
and then what are the three
things that you want people
to remember afterwards, only then
flesh out each of those three
and then think about what is
the visuals, or the
cues, code,
images, whatever. You want
that support those three elements.
I,
think many people,
I was used to opening up
PowerPoint and jumping in and
just, waaah, loads and loads
of text. And it's really,
really hard to then
edit that down.
Whereas if you step away
from PowerPoint, or Keynote,
or whatever it is you're
using or even Quarto,
and just think about what
are those things that I've just
articulated then--
And actually I used a mind map
tool,
which allows me to think about
what are those things and then
explode each of those and go,
what are the topics or what
things must remember to say about those,
but then work back from that.
And once I've thought that
through, then I open up
PowerPoint. And it, as I say,
it's turned around
what I've done.
- Yeah, that's a
great point, Mike.
I remember that
from last year too.
And I just took a
bunch of sticky notes,
and I remember sitting down
at my kitchen table and just
writing like as many ideas as
I had about the topic and just
putting it all over the
table and then trying to organize
those thoughts a bit into
little groups and then thinking
from then, what would
the presentation look like too.
Hey, Amanda. I see your hand
raised. You want to jump in?
- Yeah.
Full disclosure, I used
to be an educator. So
I have a lot of experience with
keeping people engaged
especially when there's a lot
going on. The conference is
busy. Some people
are there virtually,
and you want them to listen
to what you're saying and focused
on you. So definitely as few
words as possible on the slide.
And something that are now
hybrid world has given us the
opportunity to do is put a
code or a link on your first
slide to your slides and your
notes. So you can tell people,
hey, this is available to
you. So you don't need to be
frantically writing notes
if you don't need to.
Everything's in there.
Why don't we just talk,
and then keep it
very, very simple.
And that's going to help people
focus on what you're saying
more when they have
that relief like,
I don't need to write everything
down. This is available to me.
- Great points.
I will try and catch
up in the chat too,
but I see Honest you had
your hand raised as well.
- Yes.
This is
earth shattering, but
it's easier to remember,
and it's more interesting
to listen to when your
presentation has a story.
So just to remind people when
they think about preparing
their presentation if they can
share a story because that will
capture attention and
people will enjoy it more.
- Yeah, I'm really enjoying this
image you put in the chat
too, Jake, about examples of a
bad slide and a good slide.
Maybe there's some way I can
share that with the YouTube recording too.
JAKE: Yeah, absolutely.
I just have a really hard
time when someone puts just a wall
of text up. It's a little
hard to follow. So, yeah,
I think bolding is
really helpful too,
so not just change a
color but make it bold.
- The other thing was
visuals have
a limited number per slide.
It's easy to overwhelm the
audience with a billion things
that they need to look
at or on some text.
And so the things that I've
done for my slide deck at
the minute is have one big visual
and one small amount
of text in big font.
Repeat
and be consistent in
how those things look.
And consistent visual
design
also just helps people
just go, it's OK. I don't
need to fret that this is a
different animation style, or
things are different styles.
It's just you can concentrate
on the actual words.
-
I found that the big images
for a slide really helped me
remember a presentation too.
Even
my own talk last year
about community building,
I was thinking like, what
were my four main points?
And in my head I
pictured those four,
the big images on a slide. And
then I'm like, OK, I can remember.
Let's see.
Any other thoughts in the chat
that somebody wants to jump in
and share here too.
- Oh, so I just got a
preview of Laura Gast's talk,
and it's going to be awesome.
It's talking about all of this.
She's talking about the cognitive
research that helps you focus
people. So I highly
recommend it.
- That's awesome. Yeah,
I'll definitely have to add
that one to the schedule. Yeah,
I feel the anxiety
we all have about
multiple talks happening
at one time, trying
to add them all.
One topic,
or one follow up question
on the topic of presentations I
was curious for you all,
when you're putting
together slides for internal
presentations,
do you ever send that
information out ahead of time
with a summary
before a meeting,
or is it usually in the
meeting that's the first time
people see it? I never know
sometimes sending something out
ahead of a meeting,
are people actually even
going to go through it,
or do you assume
that they will?
MARCOS: I would say, yes,
ahead of time. But usually,
I feel like the kind of
storytelling streamline talk
you would do at this conference
is very different from the kind
of slide decks I tend to send out
at work or that get sent around at work.
The ones that work,
they're information dense,
they have a lot of numbers, a
lot of tables, a lot of charts.
You're intending to spend
time with it, and read it,
and stare at the numbers,
and understand the report out or
the results of the test or whatever,
which is very different than
this talk like the Posit talk
where they're encouraging us
to have minimal stuff on the
screen, and people are supposed
to listen to our words.
So I think it's super important
for information dense decks that are half
a document to be read and
half to be talked through as opposed
to this sort of conference
where I think the decks will be
considerably less
information dense.
- I guess,
I'm trying to also figure
out what's the difference then in
presenting a story to people
in a conference and getting them
to understand what you're
saying versus getting your
colleagues to understand
the key story
behind the data too.
MARCOS: Yeah,
I've been thinking about that
because I wonder how useful.
We have an internal
conference here for analysts,
and I was telling some
folks maybe something like
Articulation Inc.
Coming to us before the
next internal conference would be good.
But that's because
for that conference,
it's a lot of people reporting
out of their area of expertise.
So it's like people,
or teams talking to teams
that don't usually work in them,
so a giant blast of
numbers and data is
out of context and you need--
a storytelling
would be helpful.
Whereas
if it's your own team
and you're just kind of like,
people already know,
heard what you've been talking
about for a couple of months,
and then you're
just showing, well,
here's what happened
with the A/B test,
I think it can be more
information dense.
So I think it really depends
on the audience and how familiar
they are with the
stuff beforehand.
I feel like I'm dominating
the last 5 minutes,
so I will let someone else.
- No, that's it's helpful.
Daniel, I thought
you had some chats,
or you had something in
the chat here about presentations
for leadership. Would
you want to jump in?
DANIEL: Yeah.
And I apologize for
the background noise.
I like to keep my
slides very light.
I like to use lots of images,
use a bunch of [INAUDIBLE]
color and whatnot. But when
you're meeting with leadership,
you have a very short amount of
time to convey a bunch of information.
So what I usually do is take
all of the images from my slide
deck and put them
into a sales slick.
It's usually four or five pages
but it has all of the detail
that you're going to
cover in the presentation
for both. So when
you send out both,
now they can see the slide deck
but they can also see all of
the detail that you're
going to be providing,
all of the backup and all
of the narrative prior to the
meeting. So then they
come in prepared,
and they can ask really
good questions. And
for me, it's been
pretty successful.
- That's a great point.
Thank you.
I was putting a question out
into the chat to say if there
are certain questions that everybody has
and wants to ask everybody here
feel free to put
those in there too.
I see there's a lot of
thoughts here shared on the presentation
topic. But a follow-up one on
that was, I think, from Sameer.
If you want to jump in here
and ask that to everybody.
SAMEER: Yeah. Thanks, Rachael.
Hi, everyone. Sameer here.
So I think I've been through
so many presentations myself giving them.
But
every time I give
a presentation,
there's always those jitters that
I have. And I wanted to
hear, out of curiosity,
how do you personally deal
with those presentation jitters that
you get right before
it or even during it?
- It looks like George has
some thoughts for this,
or is that a separate
question, George?
- Yeah, I do you
have some thoughts.
- OK. Cool.
- I
took some training actually when
I worked at Health Net,
giving a presentation to our
execs. And what was helpful was
really the power poses that they
had us do, which are so
weird when you start
doing them. Yeah,
mark something like
that, like the power
you get in your chair. You
get all, make your body big.
There's different ones.
I'm sure many of you have
heard of those and do them.
But for me that helps a lot
to get rid of jitters
or something like--
it's almost like doing yoga
in a way because you're stretching
your body, you're breathing,
getting the blood flowing.
But aside from that,
the other thing that
calms my jitters is rehearsing,
rehearsing it to death.
So even if it's just a
5-minute speech or 15, 20-minute speech,
I rehearse it and refine it to
where I don't need a lot of words.
But if I need, if I have the
extra time, I certainly can fill it. But,
yeah, I think rehearsing
it and subtracting from
the things I'm saying and only
providing what's needed is how I feel
more confident going into it.
- Absolutely. I always
remember that one. And
I've been using lately what
you said, Ted, to shift your--
is it to shift your
nervousness to excitement?
TED: Yep.
Yeah,
it's like, one of--
if you think of it as
nervousness that disconnects
you from the audience.
But if you think of it
as excitement that's more
fuel for you to connect.
- Yeah. No. I definitely
use that one. Last week,
I was giving a maid of honor
speech, and I was thinking of it,
everything I learned from
Articulation and putting that
into the maid of honor
speech too and trying to
shift the nervousness
into excitement.
- Another thing is, I
think it's natural to feel nervous.
I think everybody feels
nervous. So if you don't,
then that's possibly
a different sign.
But the other thing is
that if you have practiced,
then as you're
getting up to do the
actual performance as it were,
remember back that before
you did all that practice,
things were a lot worse.
So you've come a long way
since that first time you even
thought of doing
this presentation till now.
So if you've done the practice
and you've got that far,
you're good to go.
- Definitely. Deepti, I
see your hand's raised.
- This is
a trick that's helped me
because I read it somewhere
that if you're chewing gum
right before your big presentation,
it kind of tricks your
brain that because you're chewing
something, you're having lunch,
nothing must be wrong, you're
just eating like normal.
And maybe it's placebo
effect, maybe it's real,
but it has helped
me every time.
So I carry a tissue
paper right before--
put it in the pocket real quick
before going on the stage.
But that's actually
helped my jitters a lot.
And maybe it's just takes
all your nervous energy to
chewing. And your jaw hurts
later, but it's helped
me a little bit.
- Love it. Yeah.
And thank you, Alan,
for the encouragement
in the chat here. Yes.
Everybody is going to do great.
Let's get off of the
nervousness conversation
because everybody's
going to crush it.
It's going to be awesome.
But I saw, Luke, you had
a question about Quarto in the
chat. Do you want to jump in?
I think it is about if
people are building slides in Quarto.
Oh, maybe we can't hear you.
But
Luke's question was, Curious,
how many presenters are
building slides in Quarto.
I see Deepti's hand raised.
I see, Ted, you unmuted.
Does that mean you are?
- Yeah.
Sorry. I'm slow
to find reactions.
- No.
- Just curious,
is it working now?
- Yep, we can hear you now.
- Well, that's great. OK.
I know personally I've
used it a few times,
and I've enjoyed it. But when it
came to something I had to have
animation in,
I had to go back to PowerPoint
because I'm not quite that advanced yet.
But
I've also been lucky.
I go to the
Southern California R User Group
and Emil happens to be
there and does his slide.
He's done his slide craft, posts,
as well as he's done the
presentation on slide craft a
few times, and
they're really good.
- Definitely. If you wouldn't
mind sharing those in the chat,
that would be awesome
too. And Deepti,
I know you've given a great
talk on Quarto as well.
If we want to grab that one
and put it in the chat too.
OK. We can shift gears
on data visualizations,
but I'm really excited to go
back and reread some of these
comments here in the chat when
I have all of my brainpower to
dedicate to reading
the chat too.
But another question
that I was curious--
I'm going in a
completely different direction here,
but I know something
that's come up a lot in
past Hangouts is
around onboarding.
And it's usually
talked about in
more of like a negative way
of companies doing a bad job of
onboarding. And
I was just curious to
learn from you all,
what are some of
your favorite successful onboarding stories
and what made it so great
because I think there's
probably something that we all
could learn from
hearing those stories. And Jared,
I'll kick it off with you
because I see you said
something right away here.
JARED: Can you guys hear me OK?
- Yep, I can hear you.
JARED: Sorry. Yeah. No, I
think for me it's just been
every role I've taken if I've
been thrown in the deep end
having that lifeline of a mentor,
somebody who's been there and can
help steer the waters has always
put me in a position to get
a lot further, a lot faster, infinitely
much so.
I've never felt like I was
always having to go at it
alone, and then you just
kind of gradually transition from
new to semi experienced or
seasoned that then you can pass
that on to the
next person coming in. And
I haven't had the opportunity to
do that as much as I would
like. But, yeah, that's I think my big takeaway.
- Definitely. Thank
you for sharing.
I'm
seeing a few comments here
in the chat. And Melissa,
you said you have one to
offer. Do you to jump in?
- Yeah.
So I think one of
my favorite personal onboarding experiences
my boss handed me the sheet of
paper and he was like, OK, tell
me your preferred style
of being approached.
Tell me what your
pet peeves are.
Tell me what you would have
wanted to tell your last boss
that ticked you off.
So having those candid
conversations with people is
really important. And then
when I got to Peloton,
one of the things that
our enterprise data team does is
creates a user manual. So
within somebody's first couple
weeks, they go, OK,
here's what makes me tick.
Here's all these things about me
and how to approach me, what
motivates me, what
are my afraid of,
what am I really
trying to do here.
And we love it. We still
use that practice today,
and it really helps people
break out of their shell and
make connections when we've got
such a large team that's like
40 plus people. It really
breaks the ice there. So
that's a great practice.
- That's really interesting.
So it's a template that
you give to everybody or--
- It really shouldn't
be. It's really like we
keep them archived so everybody
can access them on our Google
Drive. But we want people
to make it their own,
and have fun with it, and
whatever is going to
help us understand their personality
and how they work.
- Well. Thank you.
Mark, I think I saw something
you said around 30, 60, 90
check-ins maybe.
Do you want to jump in?
- I was on mute. Yeah,
the job I'm in currently
when I first joined, there
was pretty clear like, hey,
already when you join, here's the
plan for 30, 60, 90 days.
We have a project for
you coming in. We expect this
amount of progress,
and we'll check in.
And that'll help you get both
get your feet wet but then also
provide this clear direction
rather than just ambiguous--
sit-in on meetings and pitch
in where you can is very--
you'll get up to speed at
some point with that method,
but it's just a lot quicker
I feel with that planned ahead of
time from the hiring manager.
- Absolutely.
Amanda, sorry, I missed
your hand was raised before.
- Oh, yeah.
I was just going to say a lot
of times in my experience,
when you're onboarding,
people seem to still be they're
worried you're not up to date
on the skills. But they've
just vetted you on your skills.
And so the best thing you
can do for somebody is the specifics.
Like, this is how we connect with
our server, and this is how you--
the specifics to your area.
We have this platform here
that requires this funky code.
Those are the things
that frustrate people the most.
And so those are--
if you're onboarding somebody,
those are the little details
that they really need.
And then the other thing that
we're doing in my current
position is, we have markdowns,
notebooks whatever for
all of our meetings.
All the way from here's how
you access the spreadsheet,
we put it in every
single one. So somebody's onboarding has
the opportunity to just go
through this stack of notebooks
or whatever and see how people
have done things in the past.
And that a lot of times
those little details are actually in there.
-
Something I want to get
better about when I'm helping onboard
somebody or just doing an
intro call with them is just
reminding myself that
they're being thrown so much
information right now,
and they're not going to
retain every single piece of information.
So if I could be the person
to actually tell them a story
about a customer or something
that they're able to remember
rather than
just throwing more facts at them
and giving them more time to
come ask about the facts,
but to at least understand the
culture by the story that I'm telling.
Let's see. Hands are
raised. I saw, Marcos,
I think yours went up
first. You want to jump in?
- Yeah, it's completely.
I'm sorry. I did miss.
I'm multitasking here, so I
missed who was speaking last,
but I completely
agree with the idea.
When we onboard new
data scientists,
I assume that they
know Python, know pandas, they know
how to be a data scientist,
but they don't know all the
quirks of where our data is
hidden, how the weird
parquet files that we use,
not weird but the unique
parquet files that we use to
store our data and
how it's organized
by date, tables.
So we have some very
formal SQL training that introduces people
to our enterprise,
SQL type tables.
But then I have written some
Jupyter Notebooks that are very much--
they don't--
they're very lead by the nose.
They just basically show,
and so something they can
refer back to later like,
how do I load this kind
of data? Oh here, it is.
I did it in this notebook.
And so it leads them
through a step by step like,
loading some data,
making a toy model,
using some of the quirky tools
that we built internally.
And I do think that is
the most important thing,
at least for new
data people is. Yeah,
we know they can
understand trends,
and they can do data analysis,
but what are the quirks of our
system and how can we best help
a new hire understand
those quirks.
- Absolutely. Adrian, I
saw your hand was raised.
- Hi. Yeah,
so a couple of comments that it
depends on the size of the organization.
Typically, if you're
an enterprise, there's
an onboarding team. You really
don't have to worry about that.
Earlier there was a common
man on markdown files.
Yes, definitely documentation
to be able to onboard
those team members.
But what I found more important
is being onboarded even to the culture
of the organization.
In my current role--
well,
when I joined my current
enterprise I'm with right
now, it was so huge.
And one of the
comments that I asked
during my
interviews is,
will there be learning opportunities
to grow, the path to--
and
the interviewer just
went, haha, yeah,
and then he just kept on going.
And I really didn't get why
he joked like that and he just--
anyways,
I now understand why
because, oh my gosh,
there's so much enablement
in my organization.
It's just stupid every
week. There's just so much.
So now I get it.
Had I had a mentor that
could have said, oh yeah,
there's more than enough.
So I think having or
pairing a new hire with a
seasoned employee, a
mentor, helps tremendously,
and to onboard into the
culture because all the technical stuff
that's documentation.
We're all smart
here. You could read.
You can move forward to
it. If there's a hiccup,
the mentor will be able
to support you there.
So I think that's my
big take on onboarding,
definitely a mentor.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I'll have to go through
and watch the recording again and
take what's in the chat,
but I can see mentor being
one of those that's right at the
top of the list here.
Jake, I see your hand
raised. And then, Jordan,
I'll call on you
after this too.
- Yeah. We have a
four-week onboarding where I work, and
it's like drinking
from a fire hose.
It's where does the data
come from, data privacy,
it's the tools we use, we
use a variety of tools.
So I think something that's
been really helpful is they
added a analytics
workflow wrap-up.
And so it's just like, hey,
these nuggets that we mentioned
that you might have missed are
very important. And so
it's just is something
that I think they can
reference for a while after onboarding.
That's how I present
it to them is,
here's a slide deck but also
keep it handy because there's a
lot of little things that make
your life a lot easier.
So after they've gone through
where the data comes from and
all that other stuff,
we just do this wrap
up to connect the dots,
and it seems to be
helpful for folks.
- Yeah. Thank you.
And Jordan, you want
to jump in here next?
JORDAN: Sure Yeah.
And I think in the same vein
as that idea of having a mentor
and having that
seasoned veteran,
probably someone within your
team or department who will
help you get through those
sort of things, is also
getting some experience and
understanding outside of your
team, specifically
when you have--
I've seen a lot of really
brilliant programmers get into
a new industry and not really
know what the data that they're
looking at is, or where it's
come from, or why it matters.
So I think having a good
understanding of the positions
that you're probably helping,
or the departments that
you're probably helping with
their data, is just getting
to know what are they doing,
what are the things that
are important to them.
And then also it helps
with understanding why the
terminology they're using
doesn't make any sense to you
or why specific data
terminology to you just doesn't
make any sense to them and just
helping bridge that gap and
really getting a better overall
experience about what this
company is doing,
what your goals are and
how you can think about
some stuff that isn't
directly in front
of you as well.
- Absolutely. OK. Maybe we'll
shift gears a little bit here.
I see Zoe you had asked a
question in the chat. Do you to
just ask it live, and then
I can call on some people
who put answers there too.
- Thank you. So
we've had a couple of
job interviews out.
So I work in the
NHS in England,
and we've had quite a number of
them. So it's taken a lot of
brain power to get through
all the application forms.
But what I would like to
do is just check with people what
kind of experiences that you've
had that are really good to
use. So I've
mentioned about tests.
We've all agreed from ourselves
that tests didn't really work
out, and does it really
show if somebody very good.
So it's just having that idea.
We are restricted by some
of the things we have to do.
We must always ask the same
question of every single
candidate because it's part of the
public sector approach that we have.
And we'll have the same amount
of time pretty much unless
people have some
extra requirements,
but it was just
ideas from people.
It will all be online as well.
So maybe things like questions,
because sometimes they can be
quite long, can go into the
chat for example.
We're going to give them
in an advance actually.
We're going to go against the
grain in our industry and send
them out, but other
things like that,
those little tip bits that
people have enjoyed or appreciated.
- Yeah. I love that everybody's
jumping in on this thread here.
Libby, do you want
to jump in first?
- I'm sure I don't
remember what I said.
Oh, OK, I said that I really
enjoy it when I can tell that
the interviews that I'm in
are focused on me as a person,
and who I am, and
if I'm going to fit,
and if I'm a good human
being versus my skills because you
can get anybody in
there with the skills,
making me feel like who I am
matters to the role and that my
soft skills are also valued
has been really important for me
because I'm a technical person
who has great soft skills. So
hearing that those are
valued is pretty great.
And recently I had a
really good interview where
I had sent questions
ahead of time.
I think I had sent four
questions. I do that a lot.
I send things ahead of time
as much as possible to help people
be prepared for things.
And then the interviewer just
took my questions and let them
frame the interview.
I will just go through
and answer your questions,
and you can answer
back to me with counterpoints
or whatever from your
experience. And that worked
really, really well and
made me feel really welcome.
- That's great. And Toni I
see you had some ideas too.
TONI: Yeah.
I've been through some
processes recently for the US
Federal government,
so similar constraints around how
fluid you can be. But there
is a pilot that they're
doing called the [? Smeaky ?]
Way Process. And so its
subject matter expert driven.
And as part of that process,
they allow you to do
a use case and provide
a coding sample,
which is a great way to
highlight your skills because normally it's,
like you said, being
in the public sector,
you're very constrained and don't
get to kind show your
individuality and skill set.
But I do think there's
a fine line between asking individuals
to demonstrate their skills and
at some point making them feel
like they're doing free work
in order to prove themselves.
And so it's definitely
a fine balance.
- Definitely. OK.
I see a lot of people jumping
in here with some ideas too. So
if you want to unmute and
add some more context to what you
added there, I'll
keep my eyes out.
I see
Jake, Mike, and Abigail you
all added some thoughts.
OK. Abigail, you
put another thought.
Let's have you read yours too.
ABIGAIL: Oh but what
I just said so--
- Yeah.
ABIGAIL: So I ask
every data scientists, there
are some standard questions I
ask, and you try to give
everybody the same questions.
And the answers I get from
people with equivalent resumes
range from having no idea to
they give me the right answer.
And then they're like, OK,
but there's actually a
more complicated answer. I'm like,
nope, you got it 100%.
We're done with that question.
So yeah,
it's really important for me
to do technical questions because
you see somebody with a resume,
and it's really incredible,
or you see somebody with
a resume. You're like,
this isn't that good, but
then they just know the answers.
So we do the soft
skills too. But
I got to ask
technical questions.
- Thank you all for sharing
your thoughts here in the chat.
It's nice to get to see
them organized on a thread here too.
I kind of like this
format here in the chat.
Bolivar,
I see you asked
a question about
starting a user group and would love to
have you jump in here and ask that.
- Hello. Hi.
Well, I've been listening
to you all for a little bit
while I do other work.
Yeah. So I am at
Tulane University.
I'm a graduate student in
the ecology and evolutionary
biology department.
And
the group has been
around for a little bit,
but it had a COVID hiatus.
And now we've rebranded,
and we call ourselves TWERC,
and it's very New Orleans,
Tulanians Who Enjoy R Coding. And
I'm just one of the
collaborators, organizers, and
trying to workshop
ideas and how to
get people involved,
I guess what are the best
onboarding strategies
of like, hey,
bringing people in and
getting them interested or comfortable.
Some folks come
and they're like,
a lot of graduate students
have a crash course in R or
a rough relationship with
R when they don't have a
more coding background.
I'm one of those. But now this--
I'm trying to get more
involved and get better at it.
So just wanting to
hear from you all.
- Awesome. Well,
thank you for being
one of those community organizers.
I see Greg has some thoughts
here. You want to jump in, Greg?
- Yeah, absolutely. I could
speak to you. I lead--
I work for Charles Schwab,
and I lead the data science
at Schwab User Group.
We're actually trying to
schedule something with Rachael
and Posit pretty soon
for our next meeting.
But our last meeting,
I think, we had
a little over 200, 230 or
so users from across Schwab
come in and hang out.
But
I'll just echo it hasn't
always been that way.
We started out really small.
We started out as an R
user group, just purely R,
moved to R and Python,
then moved to data science.
And when we were the R
user group, it was basically the same
five people
who were just getting together
monthly and presenting back and
forth to each other.
And I came in with zero
R knowledge too. I was a SAS,
SQL user at the time and
wanting to learn R. And so
everything was
really cool to me.
They were showing
me basics of dplyr,
and I thought it was awesome.
But we started small.
I'd say a couple of things
that we've always tried to emphasize
is that all levels of skills
and ability are welcome.
So we've got some folks
who come in and bring
neural networks and
self-learning maps and just
really complicated financial topics.
We've got PhDs
presenting back to us.
The specifics of which are
probably over a lot of people's
heads, but everyone finds
it really interesting.
But we also encourage the
person who just learned how to
do something cool in
R, in dplyr, in
Python, whatever it is,
if you've just
learned the basics.
We had somebody who was--
I was just posting about
something I was pretty proud of.
We had a user who figured out
how to connect to our big data
environment via Python rather
than using the console.
Those are just small wins.
So if you can include everyone,
I think is really good chance,
plus giving everyone a
chance to present too.
There's so many folks out there
that the way that they really
learn and really expand is
by pushing themselves to present
even if it's something
that they just learned themselves
that might be on the
more basic end. So
that's really helped.
And I remember five years
ago when we started this,
the R and Python community here
was just so fractured and so
small. And you really had to--
mainly it was basically Google
and Stack Overflow to figure
out your answers. It still is
to some extent, but now we have
200 something people who come
together at least once a month
plus team channels and stuff,
and we're all helping
each other and deploying packages
that we can all share
and things like that.
But just encourage you to
keep it going. Thank you.
- Thank you.
- That's amazing to hear
also how
much the group has grown,
but also congrats on deploying
your first Shiny app to
shinyapps.io. I just saw
that in the chat too.
- Yeah.
I've only deployed them
internally for work before.
This was my first personal app,
and I was expecting Linux
and package dependency errors and
all kinds of things. But, man,
shinyapps.io I was
done in like 5 minutes.
- On the community topic too,
I feel like something helpful to
just add or say too is, I
know we do have a
tendency to celebrate as
things get to be
really large groups,
and that's amazing too when we
have a ton of people engaged.
But also even if you have
a small group of people coming
together once a month,
that's awesome too.
So it doesn't always have to
be a huge group. We have a
data science community builder coffee hour
that we do once a month. And
there's about maybe
seven
of us that will join
pretty frequently,
and we always have
great conversations there too.
And that's been something
I have to remind myself.
It doesn't have to be a huge
group to be a successful
community too.
But
I say that because if
anybody is organizing communities and
wants to be a part
of that group,
let me in the chat here, and
I'll send a note over to you too.
But Ted I know you were
tagged on that question in the chat.
Do you to jump in here with
any other thoughts too?
-
TED: I think part of it,
and I'll talk about
this at Posit Conf,
is really making it easy
for new members to contribute. And
I think there's a lot of
different models you can do that.
And I'll talk about what we do
in the Portland R User Group, which is
everyone brings
in their problems.
And it normalizes that
you're having problems,
that problems are OK and that
you don't need to know everything.
So that's--
it's
one of those things I feel
like as a community organizer,
you have to have a light touch
with answering questions,
try to let the community
answer it because it empowers people.
- Absolutely. I was trying to
type in the chat as well. I
have this data
science community builder Quarto
site I've been building,
but I want to keep making
this better with thoughts from you
all. And especially all the
research and work
you've been doing, Ted,
I feel like we should
incorporate that into it too.
But I've just shared
it in the chat.
TED: Yeah, for
sure. Definitely.
And the community builders talk
or coffee hour is super fun.
It's great, so just my plug.
- Thank you.
Let's see. George,
I see you had a question
about data governance.
Want to jump in here?
- Oh, yeah, thanks.
Yeah, data governance.
Yeah,
specifically about APIs if
anyone has any experience with
that because we're--
we're generally just rolling
out like a data governance
effort at our company, and
I'm in charge of my domain. But
considering that we might
start sharing data with
others citizen data scientists
not only traditional reports in
our system but
also through APIs,
that's something that I never
really touched before I'm just
wondering if anyone has
experience with best practices
or any suggestions
or any potential
pitfalls that I'm not
maybe looking at right now,
any governance--
ADRIAN: Hey, George.
This is Adrian.
That's a loaded question
because there's so much
involved with governance.
If you like, feel free
to reach out to me,
and I could talk to you
specifically about what we've
done with several enterprise
clients because we've set up,
I've personally set up,
well, personally
led a team with
setting up enterprise data
catalogs which includes
obviously governance. But I'll put my
email in the chat, and we could--
feel free to reach
out to me afterwards.
- Oh, cool. Yeah,
I appreciate that.
- Any other thoughts.
- Maybe it would help if I--
- I see Marlene unmuted, so
she has some thoughts to share too.
- Oh, I always have thoughts,
whether they're shareable
is a whole other question.
So just so I'm clear, is
your question more about the how
to or more of the
logistics of sharing and/or permissions based?
- It's maybe not so
much the logistics, but it's like--
because I think we're
concerned, and specifically I'm
in HR, so I have HR data
privacy
demographics and a lot
of sensitive data. And
making that available through
APIs sounds pretty exciting to
a lot of citizen data
scientists. So they're like,
yes, we can finally get
some data, do our own analysis.
I want to support that,
but then I'm also like,
that's a lot of data to put out
there. And we can do security, so logistically,
I'm not really all that concerned
but maybe more like from a
expectation level or level setting
or culture standpoint. How do you
roll that out to people,
anyone Yeah, that's
what I'm looking at right now,
maybe more of that.
- I'll throw my email
in the chat as well.
So the last data set that
I worked with APIs was around
food safety data, which
is super sensitive.
That's basically like
HIPAA data for all of us.
That's what it is for
the agricultural world.
And so they are very sensitive
about who gets to see what and
who gets to access and
pushing and pulling of sensitive information.
So if you want, we
can chat about that.
If you're at Posit Conf, then
we can chat about it there,
or we can connect on
a Zoom call or email,
whatever floats your boat.
- Yeah cool. I will
be there, so yeah.
Give me your info,
and we'll meet up.
- OK. Jake, I see you had
a question about mentors.
Want to jump in here?
- Oh, yeah,
just sometimes I get really in the
weeds of some issue, and I just
really wish someone could just
explain to me what I'm missing.
And it seems to be out of
scope for some of the places.
It's not out of scope, but
I'll put it on Stack Overflow,
and it'll just sit for a month.
And I
want to fix it by end of day,
and I can see in my mind like--
I don't know.
I just wish I had someone I
could tap on their shoulder and say,
what's going on
here, and how do I
get this thing working?
I've done a lot of
meta-programming just like
reading in code as the data--
I don't know. It's just--
I find myself in these deep
dives and then just get stuck.
-
I bet there's somebody that you can
find here to be that person with you.
Let's see.
I see there is a lot of responses
to Jake on here
on this question.
Does anybody want to jump in?
- I
just clapped instead of raising
my hand because I don't
know how reactions work.
I have been doing something
recently that has been super,
super helpful, Jake, which
is just having working sessions.
In fact, I have one later
today with a friend.
I have them weekly just getting
on one on one with somebody for
an hour or 90 minutes
and working on stuff.
And it's so helpful to just
be able to talk something through
with somebody and be like,
I'm trying to do this,
and this isn't working.
And sometimes somebody will say,
oh, have you heard
of this package,
and I've never
heard of it before.
So even if they're
not a mentor,
peer mentoring has been
really valuable for me.
So I would encourage
people, yeah,
it's not always somebody who has
10 years of experience over me.
Sometimes it's somebody who has less
experience than I do who's like, oh,
have you thought of this super
basic solution and maybe I was
being too complicated
in my head. Yeah.
- That's great.
And I see a lot of people
have mentioned the R for Data
Science Slack community too, and
that's a great place to go.
Join if you aren't
in there already.
And thank you Saptarishi for
putting the link in there to
join. I'll re-share
it in the chat too.
But I see some hands raised.
Amanda, do you want to jump in?
-
Just really quickly I wanted
to agree completely with what
Libby just said because,
especially during the early
pandemic, co-working was like
awesome just because I learned
so much from people who were
outside of my field.
They were just friends across
the country and we would just
be co-working just working.
And then you can shoot a
question out or wonder about
this or whatever it also
helps keep you motivated.
It's funny.
I wanted to echo something
Libby has said recently outside
of this chat that instead
of necessarily thinking about, oh,
I need a mentor for
this, or I need this
type of person,
focusing more on just
building friends,
making friends in the community
that you can then just text.
And it's really, really
difficult to do sometimes,
especially because I
know I'm an introvert,
but just making more friends that
you can text in that way
is such a silly way to think
of it. But it can really help.
- Definitely.
And I know I'll give a
shout out here for Libby's lightning
talk at the Posit Conference
on making data friends too.
Yeah,
everybody feel free to plug
your Posit Conference talks in
the chat too and share the
links to them because I would
love to see how many
people here are giving talks too.
Zoe, I see your hands
raised. You want to jump in?
- Thanks. It's
echoing really what people
have said in the chat and also
Amanda in answer to Jake's question.
I'm part of the NHSR community,
and we have a Slack group.
And so it's part of that.
You know that you have a
community when other people
answer your questions for
you. And even when I ask,
I get people answering.
And so my mentoring that I've
had has been from whoever
answers sometimes.
And although I don't
know people specifically,
and think it does hit that
introversion level, we chat a
lot through text, but I've
never actually spoken to these
necessarily people
face to face.
But I know that sometimes if
I put a question out certain
people will latch on to these
ones because they're so good at
that particular area.
And also what's really great
is when somebody else says,
I can't solve it either.
This is a big problem
because you said when you put
it on Stack Overflow and then
nobody answers for
months and you're like,
is that just because
I haven't worded it,
or is everybody really
this lost? It's really
heartening to have a
couple of people go, yeah,
this just doesn't work,
what's happening?
And then at least you've kind
of commiserated together,
and you're not alone anymore.
So the mentoring has never
really been one to one. But,
as you say, if
you find friends,
then you can go up
to people and say,
can you help me with this,
particularly if it kind of
strays into more career focused
as opposed to problem focused.
You can then trust
people because you've tested their
technical knowledge as much as
anything and that they're there
for you when you're really
struggling with stuff.
So, yeah, go about
it a different way.
I think maybe just be
part of a community.
Just listening
sometimes helps well.
We call them lurkers
I suppose in Slack,
and that's fine. That's great.
People are really taking a
lot away from the Slack groups.
- I love that point.
So it's just helpful sometimes to
know somebody else can't do it either.
I wanted to circle back
for a second to George's question
before because Alan,
I see you shared some
other thoughts in the chat.
Is it OK if I pull
you in here to share that?
- Yeah, I think
my thoughts were
regardless of the rollout
method the way you make
that data available.
I think being sort
of a facilitator or enabler
as long as it takes is
really important so that you set up
really clear expectations about
what is this data good for,
what does it support well versus
what does it not support well.
And that way you
can be riding along,
helping people think about in
your case compliance issues or
those kinds of
things in particular.
And it's a whole lot easier,
and we found this over
the course of trying to course
correct some big long
multiyear projects,
it's a whole lot easier to
do that at the beginning than later.
So it's really exciting to roll
stuff out and also it's really,
really helpful
and important to--
everybody look around the table
and you go, OK, wait. Let's
do this slowly. Let's do
this really carefully.
But it's a real balance of
feeling success on the part of
your team and your mission
and setting up your stakeholders
for longer term success
and stability and stuff.
- Thanks so much, Alan.
I know we are getting to
the end of our hour here.
So I wanted to see if
there were any questions I
perhaps missed from the chat
here that you wanted to ask
everybody feel free
to raise your hand.
But I love just getting
to scroll through the chat as
we're having the conversation too
and just see some of the
things that people
are celebrating too,
which is why ask
before we leave,
what are some things that everybody
is proud of this past week.
It's always a fun way to learn
a little bit more about people this way.
Marlene, I saw you just
reached a new goal in lifting.
I just
scrolled past that in the chat.
I see about Shiny
apps being deployed.
So always love to hear those
things in the chat too.
Any other
questions? Oh, people
started journaling.
My thing I'm proud of is that I
did my maid of honor
speech last weekend and successfully
got up there and didn't
cry or get too
emotional through it,
which is OK. But I
made my way through it.
- What was your final wedding
attendance count for the
summer? I know you were
going to lots of weddings.
- Oh, we still have two
more, but it was eight.
But we had three last weekend.
- Oh my gosh, three
in one weekend?
- They were great though.
Let's see.
Also
on what people are proud of,
I see Mike pointing out to
his YouTube video. I just watched
that video, Mike.
It was amazing,
so highly recommend
everybody checking it out.
Anybody have anything
else they want to share?
- Thanks. That was
shameless promo.
- Wait, I don't see
the YouTube video.
- Mike's a rock star if
nobody knew that yet.
- Oh, there it is. I see it.
- So is Ted, but he
keeps it very quiet.
- Ted, we need some
YouTube videos there too.
TED: Oh,
I guess cascade R.
- Nice.
Well,
thank you all so much for
joining today and hanging out with us.
Thanks for
bearing with us all too as
we figure out how to do these
without a featured leader
and having us all join in the
conversation. I thought
that was fun today.
Thank you all.
Have a great rest of the
day and see you either virtually
for Posit Conf or maybe
in person next week too.
Bye, everybody.
It's great to hang out.
- See y'all later.
- Bye bye.